Let's take a look at how
to add ads to your site.
In order to serve ads on your site,
you need an account with
one of the ads providers.
We will use AdSense account for
our demo.
We'll chose to show you how
to create responsive ad units
because you are building
a responsive site.
Right?
So use responsive ad units.
Responsive ads automatically resize
based on the size of the device and
the width of the parent container.
This will ensure that the ad works in
line with your responsive layout and
the site will look great on any device.
So, first step, we're opening the home
page of AdSense, and clicking on my ads.
Then we'll click on new ad unit,
and we'll give it a name.
For our purpose, we'll call it demo two.
We're choosing the responsive size,
like we said before, and
then we have the option
to choose the type.
Let's go with the default here.
Then we could choose the style.
I like this one.
And of course you could do here the best
to match the theme of your site.
And then we are just clicking,
save and get the code.
Now all you need to do
is just to copy and
paste this inline code to your html.